♪ ♪ ♪
- Sa réputation dépasse
les frontières du Québec :
un produit du terroir
confectionné avec soin
qui fait notre fierté.
Mais une grande partiertie
de notre sirop d'érable,
même celui qui est certifié
bio, pollue l'atmosphère.
PIERRE-LUC CARON,
propriétblière PL Caron
- Tu brûles du pétrole pour
faire un produit biologique,
c'est... un non-sens, un peu.
T'sais, si on mettait sur
uettes de sirop "fait
avec du pétrole brûlé à 100 %",
je pense que ça serait pas
vendeur, hein!
- Environ la moitié detout le st
dans la province est bouilli
dans des évaporateurs qui
fonctionnent au mazout.
Pour produire 10 litres
de siropen moyenne
6 litres de carburant.
STÉPHANE GUAY, acériculteur et
biologiste Érable & Chalumeaux
- Si tu les fais à l'huile,
sucre qui a la plus
grosse empreinte carbone au
monde. Et si tu les fais au bois
ou électrique, tu as le sucre
qui a la plus petite empreintec.
- Au total, l'industrie
acéricole rejette plus
30 000 tonnes de gaz à effet
de serre chaque année au Québec.
ROBERTO LANDRY,
propriétaire, Érablière BLP
- Nous autres, il faut avoir
une conscience sociale, itou.
On peut pas produire...
dire qu'on va s'en aller
vers les voitures électriques,
puis on va produire du sirop
d'érable avec du mazout.
À un moment donné,
ça tient pas la route.
- Roberto Landry va mettre
au rancart ses deux évaporateurs
au mazout après la saison
des sucres. L'an prochain,
c'est un appareil alimenté
par des granules de bois,
donc beaucoup moins polluant,
qui prendra leur place.
Un silo contenant les granules
devra aussi être installé.
- C'est un évaporateur qui va
se monter autour de 200 000 $.
- Mais en retour, l'acériculteur
verra sa facture énergétique
baisser, alors que le prix
du mazout a explosé.
- À 1,51 $ du litre,
c'est plus de l'ordre
autour de 50 % qu'on va
sauver en coûts d'énergie.
- Et en plus, il pourra obtenir
une subvention de 100 000 $ de
Transition énergétique Québec.
C'est le montant maximal
prévu dans le programme
destiné à réduire les gaz
à effet de serre dans
le secteur acéricole.
Même scénario pour
Pierre-Luc Caron, qui va, lui
aussi, passer à un évaporateur
aux granules de bois.
- Un évaporateur, ça dure
à peu près 15 à 20 ans.
Je me voyais pas brûler
du mazout encore 15 ans, là.
C'était... clair, c'est
une source d'énergie
qui est dépassée.
- Les acériculteurs
peuvent aussi se tourner
vers des appareils électriques.
C'est ce qu'a fait Yvon Tremblay
il y a neuf ans et il ne
reviendrait pas en arrière
YVON TREMBLAY, propriétaire
Érablière Yvon Tremblay
- C'est facile d'opération,
c'est vraiment informatisé
à mort, puis c'es
bouillir avec ça.
C'est cinq fois moins
dispendieux; on sauve
énormément. À la place
d'être e "fuel"
que je consommais, je consomme
environ 4000 $ d'électricité.
- Mais la conversion
se fait plutôt lentement.
des cinq dernières
années, le sirop d'érable
fabriqué dans des évaporateurs
au mazout est passé de 52 à
47 % de ion totaleion totaleion.
- Bien souvent, quand tu es tout
installé à l'huile, l'huile,
c'est simple d'utilisation.
- C'est la peur du changement
que c'est que c'est que c'est .
- Jacques Boucher accompagne
les acériculteurs qui veulent
remplacer leur évaporateur.
Selon lui, les réticences
vont finir par s'estomper.
JACQUES BOUCHER, Club d'encadr.
techn. en acériculture de l'Est
- On est habitué avec notre
système, puis bon, ça va-tu
bien marcher, qu'est-ce que
ça va apporter comme problème?
On va attendre que le voisin
l'ait fait, puis si ça march
bien, je vais le faire.
Avec l'augmentation du pétrole
qu'on connaît cette année,
je suis convaincu que cet été,
il va y en avoir b
qui vont y réfléchir.
- Ça prend comme... une masse,
admettons, pour diriger les gens
vers d'autres choses.
- Selon ndry,
les producteurs doivent
absolument effectuer
un virage vert.
- Ça veut pas dire que les gens
uisent aveuisent aveuisent aveu,
c'est pas des bons producteurs,
c'est pas ça non plus, là.
Mais le consommateur...
il va falloir se diriger versce.
- Ça ajoute de la noblesse
à notre produit de...
de pas brûler du pétrole.
♪ ♪ ♪
- L'industrie acéricole
veut rédmissionsmissionsmissions
de gaz à effet de serre
de 29 % d'ici 2030.
Mais si elle veut y parvenir,
de nombreux producteurs
suivre l'esuivre l'esuivre l'ese
de Roberto Landry et
de Pierre-Luc Caron.
Ici Olivier Bachand, Radio-
Canada, dans le Témiscouata.